شاام ساعات صعبه عاشتها رفح بسبب القصف
والاستهداف الاسرائيليه في اكثر من منطقه
بالاضافه الى مناطق اخرى ان كان في محافظه
الوسطى او في الشمال التفاصيل
لدي بالفعل ازدهار ربما خصوصيه رفح هي
التي تحدد هذا القصف الاسرائيلي او الجيش
الاسرائيلي بات يركز استهدافات منذ الليله
الماضيه على مدينه رفح القصف الاسرائيلي
ربما مستمر على رفح منذ عده ايام وبات
اكثر حده واكثر كثافه لكن خلال الليله
الماضيه ربما يمكن وصف هذه الليله بانها
الاعنف على رفح منذ بدات العمليه البريه
على قطاع غزه الجيش الاسرائيلي ركز
استهدافات على منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه
وعندما نتحدث عن رفح وخصوصيه رفح فهي
خصوصيتها من خلال الاكتضاض السكاني في
مدينه رفح بسبب الاعداد الكبيره من
النازحين التي لجات الى مدينه رفح بعد ان
طلب منها الجيش الاسرائيلي التوجه الى
مدينه رفح وبعد ذلك يقصف الجيش اليش
الاسرائيلي هذه المدينه بمنازلها بخيام
بالمناطق الغربيه فيها بمناطقها الشرقيه
بمناطقها الشماليه بمناطقها الجنوبيه كل
هذه المناطق تعرضت الليله الماضيه الى قصف
عنيف من الطائرات من الزوارق الحربيه من
الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه المتمركزه
على الحدود الشرقيه لمدينه رفح قبل قليل
ما جددت المدفعيه الاسرائيليه قصفها لتلك
المناطق الشرقيه لمدينه رفح منطقه صوفا
منطقه مطار رفح ال الذي دمر من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي في اوقات سابقه وا او في سنين
سابقه ايضا قصفته المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
المنطقه الفاصله ما بين خانيونس ورفح ايضا
تعرضت الى قصف عنيف من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه سلسله من الغارات شنتها
الطائرات على هذه المنطقه الفاصله ما بين
مدينه خانيونس ورفح وايضا سمع دوي
انفجارات عنيفه كانت ناجمه ايضا عن قصف
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه للمناطق
ايضا الجنوبيه لمدينه خانيونس وهي منطقه
قيزان النجار وقز رشوان وجوره اللوت وهذه
المناطق ما زالت تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه كذلك
الزوارق الحربيه كثفت من قصفها فجر هذا
اليوم وصباح هذا اليوم
لمنطقه المنطقه الغربيه لمدينه رفح وهذه
المنطقه بالتحديد هي منطقه المواصي وهذا
يعني ان هذه المنطقه الذي تحدث الجيش
الاسرائيلي انها منطقه امنه ويتواجد فيها
عشرات من مقرات المؤسسات الدوليه
والمؤسسات المحليه على اساس انها امنه
وكان يرسم الجيش الاسرائيلي ويميزها على
الخرائط التي يطلب من السكان ان يتوجهوا
اليها وبالتالي القصف من الزوارق الحربيه
الاسرائيليه على تلك المناطق هي مناطق حتى
الان القصف يطال الشاطئ ولم يطال اي مقار
او اي خيام او اي من خيام النازحين
ومخيمات النازحين لكن القصف يسمع دويه في
اصوات في مناطق مختلفه من مدينه رفح القصف
ايضا على رفح ربما تركز خلال ساعات فجر
هذا اليوم وساعات المساء على منا المدنيه
فلسطينيه حي تل السلطان وربما هو الحي
الاكثر اكتظاظا بالسكان في مدينه رفح تعرض
الى قصف عنيف من الطائرات قصفت الطائرات
منزلا هناك وكان هناك عدد من الشهداء
والجرحى اذا تحدثنا عن الشابوره فهي ايضا
من المناطق الاكثر ازدحاما والاكثر
اكتظاظا بالسكان
وبنازير
وكذلك المنازل فيها مكتظه خيام منصوبه على
في الشوارع في على الارصفه ورغم ذلك قصفها
الجيش الاسرائيلي وهناك عدد من الشهداء
والجرحى جراء استهداف لمنزل كذلك حيت تل
الزهور وهو في المناطق الشماليه ال في
المناطق الشماليه لمدينه رفح وقصفت
الطائرات الحربيه وكان هناك ام وابنتها
شهداء كذلك في
المناطق الجنوبيه لمدينه رفح المناطق
الجنوبيه الشرقيه قصفت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه منزلا هناك وكان هناك عدد من
الشهداء والجرحى كذلك قصفت في ساعات
متاخره من مساء امس سياره تابعه للشرطه
كانت تؤمن المساعدات
واستشهد سته من عناصر الشرطه الفلسطينيه
الذين يؤمنون المساعدات ووصول المساعدات
الى سواء الى مدينه غزه او حتى الى مناطق
مختلفه في وسط القطاع وخانيونس ورغم ذلك
قصفته الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
واستشهد سته من عناصر الشرطه بالتالي
القصف الاسرائيلي على رفح خلال الساعات
الماضيه كان مركزا كان يستهدف منازل مدنيه
فلسطينيه كان يستهدف الاراضي الزراعيه
وحتى المنطقه الحدوديه ما بين رفح و مدينه
وجمهوريه مصر العربيه ايضا قصفتها
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه القصف ايضا
مستمر وربما مركز كذلك على خانيونس وكذلك
كان هناك استهدافات عده في دير البلح
وايضا في المناطق الشماليه لمخيم النصي
شكرا جزيلا لك من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام
فقط